you
[Music]
yeah thank you and it's it's a short but
so far pleasurable visit here yeah and I
must admit that I was not aware until
this morning that I am scheduled to give
a talk here I thought it would be just a
visit so I am recycling the talk that I
gave that is it earlier this week but I
strongly encourage you to guide me
through the process with a question
suggestions disagreements whatever
complains especially if you want to know
more you know deeper technical stuff on
what I am presenting because the talk is
a pity fellow on technical things and
it's more about the big picture so I
hope you will find it useful and but I'm
open to any adjustment and suggestion to
to how to how to do it so I'll start by
a little bit background about uw-madison
besides the fact that it always looks
like this right
and a but they the really important
thing of the numbers and the you know
43,000 students 22,000 to faculty and
staff three billion dollars of total
budget but what what is important for
the discussion here is that there's
always one point it is also one point
two billion dollars of external support
for research that goes into the campus
so that's a very significant research
engine that obviously is strongly
related to what I'm going to talk about
so that's the reason I wanted to make
sure that this is on the table as as we
start there so before I dive into the
more science part let me talk business
commercial and it's it's always a
challenge when you are in the business
world to decide where you are on the
vertical versus the horizontal or the
horizontal versus the vertical do you
focus on a market that is vertical very
few users with very specific requirement
or do you go horizontal and do something
that applies to everyone and what have
you and where you position yourself the
way you put your effort and all the kind
of thing is is a challenge for any
business so so with this as a background
when you work with domain scientists
then they are interested in verticals
they are interested in solving the
problem and they don't care about what
delivers to them they the solution for
the computational problem how elegant is
it does it use block chains or does it
use machine learning and whatever it is
it has to be effective
because if it's effective they will
adopt it and if not who cares and it's
not efficient it's effective because it
has to do what they need to do with the
resources that they have yes at the
amount of time that they have so so this
is sort of the vertical that researchers
of the main scientists care about
computer scientists are horizontal they
want to come up with something that
everyone will use and therefore in terms
of their science they are focusing and I
am a computer scientist so I'm supposed
to belong to this side but I would say
and we'll see later that I strongly
believe that if you want to be a
horizontal you must evaluate what you
are doing in real verticals so even if
you want to be Horizonte you cannot run
away from the verticals and and work
with them so I think the same
realization is shared with MIT that a
year ago came and said we are going to
invest a billion dollars in creating a
new college that will reshape you know
when I see MIT saying they will reshape
themselves that's huge
you know institution like this don't
reshape commercial entity restructure
every year or every six months but
organization like MIT don't reshape
themselves but the main thing is that to
reorient MIT to bring the computing nai
to all fields of study and to use all
fields of study to impact
research and development in computing in
AI so this is recognizing the fact that
there is a strong synergy between the
two areas that requires a different
approach to how an established and
successful institution like MIT is going
to move forward
so in a rephrasing the announcement of
MIT to the context of the Center for
supercomputing I claim that we
established the center in 2006 to do
exactly that on a much narrower scope of
the you know computing technology and to
do it on distributed high-throughput
computer to have impact on all fields of
study on the campus and to leverage from
this 1.2 billion dollar enterprise to do
what we do better ok so one way to
summarize what we are doing in C HTC's
to harmonize the vertical and the
horizontal now that may sound as if we
are trying to square the circle because
usually you say that two things that are
completely independent they're
orthogonal so if you think about the
horizontal and the vertical as being
orthogonal and you would say how can you
harmonize them but I believe we can
square the circle so this is the kind of
love letters we like to get from our
verticals and this is a guy that is
studying mice on on a remote island in
the
the South Atlantic with some in
evolutionary phenomenon that is it's not
understood you know why are the mice
they're twice the size of the mice in
Europe even though they arrive to this
island not by swimming from Europe but
on cargo ships that went to the to the
island two hundred years ago and
suddenly they're twice as big as their
ancestors in Europe and by the way I
learned as a result of talking to these
guys that there are two types of field
mice there the German and there the
French I don't know which one made it or
both of them made it but the thing is
that what is mr. or they don't
understand is how you can have
evolutionary process in two hundred
years because they are twice as big and
actually they're causing problem to to
divorce it's one of these little you
know an island is basically a rock in
the middle of the ocean that unless they
swim over there but that's that's a
little bit so what what we like to see
is that CH TC is the same essential to
my project this is an adoption of a
vertical I couldn't do what I did
without this they say this is the
effectiveness if you want to so in order
to do this kind of harmonization you
have to
I created this acronym as I put together
the slide you have to do D D D or E
namely you have to be able to design to
develop to deploy to operate and to
evaluate the researchers are coming with
their upper layer you have to provide
the rest which is the lower layer and
the stuff in the middle and you want to
do that you put the best you can on this
bar
you also have to make sure that you
partner with them which is their more of
a personal commitment of time and effort
and what you would you would like to aim
at or you should aim at if you really
believe in it is how can you influence
their science with the capabilities that
you offer see because the ultimate
success is if the vertical that you
created not only was adopted but change
the way they do science so if you can do
more you can do better you can do
different they may change the scientific
method to do things more different so
their science is changing a simple way
to think about it is if you science you
you formulate the problem by assuming
you can only calculate two points then
you you know that all you can deal with
is straight lines so you will not ask
question about what happens between the
points but if you can do all many points
you can start asking question about the
shape of the curve is it goes between
the two lines that's a different way to
do your science because you realize you
can do more and it's a frequent question
that I asked researcher and say what
will you do if I give you two million
core hours what and in many cases they
get the blank phase and part of it is
because researchers don't even dream of
what they can do if they had more
computing power available to them I
would argue that this is also true with
researchers in general that when you
come and say I give you two million
dollars to do your work what would you
do they didn't they didn't have these
dreams of what can I date they always
come
and say oh I don't believe I can get
that much money and I say let's assume
you have the money but at the same time
we want to take care of our horizontals
and we have been developing quite a bit
of new stuff in the area of distributed
what we call high throughput computing
and this is translated or materialized
in all the HD kondo software which is a
whole family of technologies that
obviously I don't have the time even to
start explaining all the the different
pieces and also what is nice is that we
are we were considered as significant
contributors to two Nobel prizes in
physics the first one was the detection
of the or the identification of the
Higgs boson at the at the LHC and the
second one was the detection of
gravitational waves that has proven
there the the the prediction or the
model of the Tyne Stein envisioned a
hundred years ago as being correct by
the way I shall never believe that it
can be measured because it's such a tiny
thing and measuring it and detecting it
and all this I will get back to to the
gravitational wave later the the other
part of of our work is to has been to
pioneer the the concept of research
computing facilitation which is
different than user support because it
really recognizes the role of these
individuals in bringing computing and
science together and not helping
somebody to implement a piece of
software to run on something and we use
non-technical people to do research
computing facilitation
because we learned over the years that
the technical people don't know how to
listen technical people have a solution
before you presented the problem because
the solution is what they know so they
will map whatever your problem is to
their solution and facilitation is about
finding the right solution for you and
therefore you should not have you should
learn how to listen and to understand
what the problem is rather than to focus
how to map the problem to the solution
that you know to give you a little bit
of a feeling of what we do on the ground
is we delivered last year 400 million to
hours to researchers on the campus from
250 different project and they'd about a
thousand research computing facilitation
hours and this is the snapshot of that
was before my talk at TI FR last week of
the top 10 users of CH TC in 24 hours so
we delivered 1.1 million core hours the
first one CMS is one of the LHC
experiments is representing an
international group of more than three
three and a half thousand researchers
the second one is Ice Cube I will talk
about it later is is also an
international collaboration that is
anchored at Wisconsin they did about 50%
of these cycles and then you have
individual group form from physics this
is bio magnetic resonance databank mass
bobba bobba and even here number 10 at
nutritional sciences did almost a
thousand cause solid for 24 hours to do
something
okay so that's the way it looks on the
ground and what we are doing in ch TC
and this is enabled through the research
computing facilitation this is Lauren
Mitchell who is Michael sorry that is
leading the facilitation effort and an
important part of it to teach out to
fish rather than to fish you the support
usually does the fishing and said oh let
me write for you the coda let me rewrite
this thing and let me do this kind of
thing we don't do any of this we guide
you to do what needs to be done or we
can connect you with somebody that will
help you do things but this is not what
the facilitator do and we apply the same
concept of scaling out not only to our
infrastructure but also to the
facilitation process and it's now there
are national activities that are related
to it there were several in a safe
project that were related to it so it
it's becoming more and more understood
so ice cube is a detector of neutrinos
in the South Pole and they drilled one
and a half kilometer probes into the
eyes and through the eyes they are
detecting these these particles and the
elusive particles the important thing is
that all the infrastructure is based on
HT condo it's a vertical and you may
find it interesting that GPUs are
critical to their computing capacity but
they don't do machine learning they're
using GPUs to do a simulation of the
eyes that is critical to their ability
to turn the information that they get
into the science that they that they
need and this is the distribution of GPU
our that they did over the last year and
a half where every color is a different
pool of resources or a different site or
a different organization you will see it
later that provided them with the GPUs
and at the top of the you know the the
upper value here 300 thousand hours in
you know in these columns are monthly
columns and some of the places the the
first one is university of
wisconsin-madison
they they did one one and a half million
total GPU hours in a year and a half but
GPUs are not the only thing that they
need they need also CPUs and that is
which is easier for them to get
obviously and these are again they can
go out and use CPU hours from all these
different institution we're here the top
institution in 35 million total over the
year and a half of CPU hours so the
important thing is having many colors
multicolor is good which means the
contribution is coming for many
different sources speaking about sources
this is a picture of a blazer that is
emitting particles towards earth and the
distance between this blazer and the
earth is exactly 4 billion light years
and they recently detected the particles
which they called a ghost particle that
was emitted from this blazer and by
knowing that he came and the properties
and all this and the ability of other
what's called multi messenger astronomy
to focus on this blazer that is related
to the emission because the emission was
triggered by an event that was related
to the black holes at in this in this
galaxy
so that's what we enable them to do in
terms of the computational part once
they get the signals out of the eyes
from these different detectors and I
encourage you if anyone is interested go
to you know search for it on the web and
there's a lot of interesting stuff there
but speaking about four billion years
and trying to give a meaning to the term
Monty scale so this is another love
letter that we got earlier this year in
July and saying look at this protein
image that we just created using ch TC
and this is 12 angstrom for billion
light years 12 angstrom now what we are
seeing more and more in science is that
the instruments in this case a cryo am a
microscope a they're generating a lot of
signals that require significant
computing power to turn the signal into
data before you can do advanced machine
learning on it or whatever you are doing
was data in order to get your science so
the computing barrier is more in how do
I get the data out of it rather than how
do I turn the data into the science and
this is an example so one we are getting
signals of particles that were emitted
four billion years ago and this one it
is something that was emitted from an
electron microscope that now is being
deployed in more and more universities
around the world to to study structures
and they can see things at the atomic
level
I mentioned earlier the gravitational
wave this is like oh this is a report
that came from the grouping in Germany
and again we couldn't do it without the
collaboration and the technology that we
have been doing together and here this
is a partnership that has been going on
for over 15 years now and this is common
that to to build these things it's a
long relationship across technologies
across science software and all the kind
of thing to get to where people are
because they start with one instrument
and they upgrade the instrument the
first instrument couldn't detect things
but they had to go through the first
instrument to get the second instrument
and then they made the the detection and
these instruments are big investment
so the first installation of Kondo was
at at Wisconsin at 1995 so even in our
small world we are working on on
something for quite a number of years
and we from the beginning we made sure
that we create verticals and they at the
beginning the vertical were just our
computer science department now the work
that went into Kondo we have to change
the name because we had the lawsuit
about calling a software calling it
condor and bla bla we managed to get out
of it after spending a lot of money to
buy putting an HD in front of it
and this work is actually a continuation
of my PhD work that's the reason why I
am sympathetic with with your with your
and my PhD work was strongly influenced
by the distributed computing era of the
the the mid 70s
and here's a paper that ends low
published in the computer magazine yes
we had come we had magazines in 75 about
computers you know those of you with who
don't believe that the web publication
actually I have another publication
that's from the communication of the ACM
that is even earlier in a minute or in
in a few minutes but the impulsing here
that Enslow listed the benefits of
distributed system and as you can tell
we have new generation of buzzwords that
our reprimanded were listed by angelo in
in the mid seventies and he said if you
have a true distributed system that will
be there and then you ask yourself the
obvious question how comes that if we
knew it in in the in the 70s how comes
that you cannot order through Amazon a
distributed system in a box deliver hit
deploy it and be done right and why do
you have to call these things now clouds
because you know something something new
and the reason for that is actually in a
technical report that Enslow any student
published in 81 and they said ok you
want all these good things these are the
properties that the sister must have in
order to be a true distributed system
and if it's not a true distributed
system it will not give you the benefits
and I want to focus on two elements of
this is unity of control and component
autonomy because I think the this
distress between these two
is key now you know we are trying to do
system transparency you know we now call
the virtual machine or container
whatever whatever is there the buzzword
of them but every everyone wants to may
to make it transparent so the unity of
control says that all the element of the
of the system have to be unified in a
common to achieve a common goal I know
it doesn't sound like computer science
right you never talk about the component
of a database being unified to achieve a
common goal
this sounds like social science but this
is critical when you bring together the
pieces of a distributed system you have
to assume that there is some driving
goal that they all share and they want
to achieve at the same time you have to
make sure that all the components are
autonomous because if they are not fully
autonomous you will not get all these
beautiful benefits of before now how do
you achieve this commonality of gold
with full local autonomy is the hard
problem and therefore if you are ever
presented with a distributed system and
somebody says this is it
check the unity of control and check the
autonomy and we as human don't like to
build system with local autonomy we like
to be in control we like to know about
everything and make decision for
everything rather than letting them sort
of exist and you can take it to a
question of short forces and long forces
in in physical system and you achieve
stability through the short force is not
there so you're creating some kind of
local autonomy and in creating there
so that is one of the things that have
been driving us from from the beginning
so it's very important when you do
something in this space whether it's
your PhD or a continuation of it try to
put it on on principles rather than on
the the latest buzzword of the day at
the same time if you build systems then
you have to go to the to the masters and
see what did they teach us and I assume
I don't have to introduce Dijkstra to
you but he published in 68 it was
received presented that the or I think
it's actually happening this week the
the operator oh yeah the operating
system the ACM operating system
conference is happening this week in 67
where he said if you want to build the
system understand the sequential
processes and put them in a hierarchy
and build them on a solid design where
you understand what are the pieces and
what is the relationship between the
pieces namely don't sit down at your
terminal with the latest scripting
language and start writing the system
yes he was a logician you know he wanted
to prove properties and that is but
another important part of this paper
which I it's it's a short read I
encourage you to read it was that
Dijkstra published a paper where he
listed the mistakes that they made how
many papers did you read recently where
people listed the mistake that they made
in doing anything all papers are just
saying look how great I am and here he
said we made mistake the first mistake
was that we tried to build a perfect
system which is way too complicated
which is way too involved with the
boundary and the the corners and all the
kind of things that a makes it very
complex and then also is continuously
following assumption that are changing
all the time that it you have to
simplify and you have to not build
something that can handle in the optimal
way every corner case because you end up
with nothing
the second mistake that they made it was
that they didn't focus or didn't include
the bugging in the original in the from
the beginning and this is something that
I'm sure you see all the time I'll write
it I will make it run fast the scale all
the kind of thing our debugging will
deal with it later because debugging is
the functionality the bugging is not
publishable how easy it is to debug your
latest greatest algorithm and and I can
tell you that in my group when somebody
comes to me and says I want how about if
we do this as an algorithm for doing
something and then say are you willing
to be responsible of debugging and
supporting it in the field on that many
installation yeah we don't have the
number of installation that you guys are
talking about but still we have enough
for the size of the team that we have
and typically the answer is saying no I
don't want to deal with that so then we
are not going to follow and not
implement it even though it's an amazing
algorithm because it's so complex that
we will never be able to to debug it and
proving correctness of implementation
you know how difficult it is
so taking all these principles and all
these concepts together it was
unavoidable for us to come up with with
a vision that says eh we can do global
computing via a flock of condors and we
presented it at CERN in 92 and we said
let's connect all these computers all
the kind of things and create one
worldwide I know it sounds like a cloud
right and we'll run all this and we even
have already a system that can do it we
have a demonstration of of a system that
can do it so each of these is a condor
pool that spanned from Dublin Russia all
the way through Europe to Wisconsin yes
at that time we had only 200 work
station in the pool in the early 90s and
we were able to submit jobs that
traveled through these interconnect from
Dubna to to Wisconsin actually if you
think about execution of jobs and
message passing it's a little bit
similar you enter it one place you send
your job somewhere and you get the
results back which are like an
acknowledgment so the principles of
routers and network transfer can be
applied and here we actually use routers
and gateways conceptually to move the
jobs across so if you went from from
Berlin to here you may have gone this
way to learn in Wisconsin but the fact
is that even an advanced organization
like CERN didn't get it we presented it
we but didn't
now 25 years years later they got it
they installed it there the transition
to HD condo on all their batch
processing which includes about 15,000
servers with 230,000 cause completed and
it's running and if I have time we'll
get to open science grid later we do
this whole thing worldwide but it's to
two lessons here is if you build on the
right primitives you reach things which
are unavoidable okay there are not that
many solutions to the same problem even
though it seems that you can choose here
you can choose there so anchor them on
the right principle and you have to wait
if people adopt what you are doing
quickly I don't consider this as a good
sign
so in 96 we I decided it was more me
than I said okay we have to articulate
that we are different everyone around us
is HPC and the only way that they refer
to the work that we are doing was ah
this is embarassingly parallel work and
it hurts you when people say that what
you do is embarrassing so part of what I
have been doing since is any time
somebody talks about embarrassingly
parallel I say this is pleasantly
powerless
this is naturally followed there's
nothing embarrassing about doing it and
I also coined the term high throughput
computing
and a year later I was interviewed by
HPC wire about high supercomputing which
is also a funny but here's the way that
I tried to contrast high throughput
versus high performance so high stroke
high performance measures everything in
floating-point operation per second if
you look at the top 500 list of the
machines they are they are based on
Linpack and they're giving you their
their flops
how many floating-point operation you
could do per second and by the way the
way they build these machines is really
focusing putting as much silicon as
possible into the floating something
doesn't give me my battery is I don't
have
okay let's assume that that's fine No
okay you see it does fault-tolerant is
not you know you connect and you plug in
it and you still don't have power in
there so the so they focus on flops to
be in in the top of the top 500 list
which is the biggest machine in the
world you have to run limp back once and
be faster than anyone else the
scientists that we are working with care
about floppy which is floating-point
operation per year now you know very
well that you cannot take what you can
do in a second multiply it by the number
of seconds in a year and get what you
can do in a year if you can run a
kilometer in three minutes it doesn't
mean that you can run that many
kilometers in a year right it's a
different problem and it requires
robustness but it also requires
automation why automation because there
is a huge difference between running one
job of a hundred thousand hours to
running a hundred thousand jobs for one
hour and the big machines are designed
for this i suport
is designed for that and i will not have
time to talk about what we are doing for
automation we are using DAGs and
directed at cyclic graph for capturing
the things and a you know you can find
information about it but that's the core
of the high throughput computing
again you have to be patient so I
introduced it in 96 in 2017 in National
Academy of Science report stated that
many fields today rely on high
supercomputing for discovery and then
they even said many feels increasingly
will ionize report computing for
discovery so these now a recognition
that something that didn't exist 20
years ago in a way as a concept is
critical for scientific discovery so the
good news is the tie through put is
important we try to do similar things
you know we talked about the grid you
know the grid world and it we had a
chapter in this book that was referenced
I don't know how many tens of thousands
of times because everyone who wrote any
paper about grid reference the book I
think without opening it but it says a
great she is the book we try to convince
the community that the key for the grid
is integrated mechanism that are robust
scalable and portable the community
didn't follow that and then the whole
grid movement disappeared because
everything that happened there people
said but it doesn't work and we should
sure it doesn't work because nobody
focused on mechanism that are dependable
and we have a problem in in our field
that people like to work on policies
people like to poet to publish policies
people claim that they know how to
evaluate policies doing the same for
mechanism is
much more difficult but I would argue
that if you give me a good set of
mechanisms I can get decent behavior or
performance from any system with the
policy that will take me 15 minutes to
invent but if you give me an amazing
policy and no mechanisms good luck it
will take you more than 15 minutes to
come up with the mechanism so we need
mechanism and at the end of the day you
know even when you come up with an
optimizer as we talked earlier you still
need something that will run the plan
right and if this sucks
and if this breaks half the way because
of whatever the optimizer is is not
really the solution so well I'm checking
on this because there's no there's no
time here anywhere okay we are a I can
open are there any questions any
suggestion anything we are about 10
minutes from from the hour so yeah I
have more stuff I can continue but I
will give you an opportunity to yes we
consider all of these things as normal
and and just try again no now if you
have a checkpoint we'll start for where
you are if you a if two if two nodes
disconnect we try to reconnect the
question is how long was the deacon
were the two disconnected okay so so
okay in condo there is that's where you
submitted the job that's where the job
is running and they have a relationship
which keep alive and all the kind of
stuff now if this goes away then how
long this will stay committed to the
relationship and how long this will stay
is an autonomous decision of both
players so we use this for doing life
update for example on the submit
so this submit machine may have 10,000
jobs that are running and we want to
upgrade it so actually we send a an
update to all the the workers and say
would you please wait longer because I'm
going down and it may take me longer to
come back so just keep doing what you
are doing and then reconnect because we
don't want you to be all the time
staying in the connect because if I
really crashed and the machine was burnt
and all the kind of thing I want you to
let go because there will be nobody to
take the results so the advantage that
we had or the luck is that we started
with workstations that anything can
happen it's not only that is any
engagement that happens can the the data
or the rules that govern the engagement
can change between the time that they
were advertised and the time that the
action took place so when the action
comes to take place we have to check
whether the condition for this what we
call a match are still valid and if
any partner this is the autonomy decides
to get out of this relationship everyone
is okay okay we tried so so the
mentality is if it worked
it's a miracle or it's a coincident not
if it didn't work it's a it's a problem
it's it's normal and typically when when
people come to give presentation to my
group is that they sometimes almost run
away because you know they come and say
look I did this and this and it can run
fast and that these condition and all
this and we stay numb and then when they
are done in this they ask they say okay
question saying okay what happened if
this does what happen if this goes away
what happened if this didn't fail to
communicate what happened if this buffet
is for what you know picking on on
databases because my host is the
database guy the worst thing that can
happen to you is the database that runs
out of disk space all the optimizer in
the world will not save you and it will
take you a long time to recover your
database and he just ran out of disk
it's not that it burned down you know it
stopped journaling it's up there so in
Kondo if you cannot log you shut down
and we are working hard to put into the
log a message that we shut down because
we couldn't log anymore we keep all the
time yeah it doesn't always work because
it's hard to keep space on disk but but
we we will because this is sort of we
have to be prepared for for the same to
to fall apart so that's a long long
answer to it it has to be in the DNA not
not as an afterthought anything else
so let me give you another principle
before we have to call it quit so in 92
we published the paper about here's what
we did was we were very proud about
250,000 jobs you know we do it on on at
Wisconsin poverty in in one hour these
days and in a worldwide maybe every
second I don't know something like that
but the important thing is we said look
if we listen to the user back to the
verticals and we ask them what what do
you care about and they said we want to
get access to as much capacity from a
single point and we want this point of
access to preserve our local environment
so I the you know and by the way the the
overhead here is not networking overhead
is there the effort to make it all
happen it's in the effectiveness so we
turn this into a principle that we use
throughout our system and other systems
that are built in this context including
open science grid and alike and we said
submit locally and one globally submit
to a local environment where you manage
everything locally and it's not only
that you manage things locally you use a
local namespace you look you use a local
identity space and all the kind of thing
and try to reach as far as you can so
that's by the way the reason why we
don't assume shared file system because
you cannot run globally if you assume a
shared file system you have to be
prepared I know it sounds like
containers pack everything with you and
go can you do it for everything can you
do Bobby
but my understanding from talking to to
a ghoul that one of the challenges that
you guys are facing and I understand
he's coming to visit here shortly
yeah I saw him a couple of weeks ago in
Madison and he said yes we are now
facing what you have been complaining
about for such a long time is in the
cloud environment where you need
elasticity in your in your database
management system then how how do you
grow and shrink and heat this is this is
the same kind of problem how do I give
you the data that you need where you are
going to execute and how do I bring the
data back to - right it's not identical
but it's there it's the same a
fundamental yeah and let me make a quick
comment here is that there is this whole
business of resource acquisition that is
related today to to the cloud and maybe
I'll make a comment on it later quickly
when I show you sort of one one of the
pictures of chec so so that's that's the
the thing and I for many years have been
using this picture of the desktop that
goes to the floor that goes to the
building that goes to the campus goes to
the region goes to the world you want to
sit here and run here but you want to
use everything in between it's not that
you go to the cloud and I understanding
from what I know about the Jura is that
it has been the Microsoft philosophy of
using it as an extension of your local
environment rather than taking
everything that you have and put it
there so that's the death decimate
locally in one globally but you go to
the young generation and they don't have
desktops anymore and they don't have
workstation anymore they have Jupiter
notebooks everything starts and ends in
a Jupiter notebook so the question is
and that will
we are working on just to give you a
flavor why we are not done is how do you
bring Python to condo all the binding
all the days what what do you created is
an is an API for an interface from
Python to expose what condo does is jobs
and stuff like that but also to go in
the opposite direction and to say how
can you bring the concept of high
supercomputing into the Python life and
here what we are doing is that you know
Python has map as an important construct
of capturing doing multiple things so we
created a module that we call HTML that
implements the map as a high support
computing things through kondal in the
back so the functions that are invoked
by the map are basically job that a
running installed of is all the issues
with a synchronicity and all the kind of
thing but at the end of it you have an
object which is the map object that got
populated by condo jobs but then you
have to make the object richer because
they are all the question about the a
synchronous execution of the of the of
the map so I think that that will be the
last picture I will share with you
unless there it is interesting more
later but so this is the world that we
present our CH TC users so you have the
researcher with a problem to solve this
is a workflow described as a dag a piece
of it and by the way we have chairs in
Wisconsin so not everyone is sitting on
the on the ground and the researcher is
interfacing with the count with CH T see
that basically presents all the
resources of the campus
the single accessible resource from here
so the one anyhow the 1.1 million hours
that are delivered annual a daily sorry
it's coming from a whole bunch of condor
pools of the campus over a dozen some of
their mind see HTC and some of them are
owned and operated by others but see HTC
also can bring in resources from HPC
systems a growing source of computing
power I would say in the US and Europe
now because there is significant
investment in it and they wanted to be
used for science including HTC you saw
the previous I find it a report that I
showed you go to the cloud so the the
guys at Atia file the CMS they they
expand their computing capacity using
condo into a zoo they can get 10,000
calls in a show up in 10 minutes connect
them to the condo fool at the area far
and go and the open science grid so this
is basically the world view the thing is
that really this researcher has to be
shown here with a pile of money and an
allocation and a priority that using
these resources has to be paid with and
that actually brings up I call it
capacity planning you can call it
optimization which is moving from an era
where you did capacity planning at very
low frequency once a year or once every
five years to high frequency capacity
planning because you have to decide when
to use your money to buy cloud resources
when to use the allocation to you
HPC resources and when to use your
priority to use open science grid
resources so that's as far as I can go
in the time that we have any further
questions or something which is not
related but you still are interested to
know I can try and answer yes yes we
with the checkpointing in the in the
black yeah in the black and white I mean
we I think only a year ago we decided to
stop supporting it because it became
non-sustainable we from actually in this
90 to convey workshop we sent out a list
of requests to the operating system for
workstation community and say give us
checkpointing give a check pointing none
of the solution that that were offered
to us since and there were promises that
checkpointing vivillon's and
checkpointing containers and all the
kind of thing don't work in our in our
environment and also if we are not
convinced that these checkpointing is
reliable it becomes unsustainable right
if if somebody is running a job in your
system that was checkpoint a 20 time and
crashes whose fault is it the jobs fault
or your checkpointing and this can
consume way too many resources to for a
group like ours so we couldn't we could
we couldn't find anyone to do
checkpointing in a different way than
what we were doing with
you know writing out the decor and more
and more of the jobs complex scripts and
other crazy things so yes it would be
amazing if we what we are doing our best
today is to support application to do
their own logical checkpointing so the
days we need to understand that we need
to move the things reliably back to the
origin where is it it's not even
non-trivial in this case how is the
signal how do they tell you that they
are done you know they usually they want
to shut down and they want to restart
because only when you restart you verify
that the check point that you created
it's valid because how long do you keep
there the check it but yeah in the in
the black and white there is we we we
did it but we had to give up
we we had users who youth checkpointing
to address also the local the local file
system there we'll start the job read
everything that they need checkpoint and
then move so there are many science
applications that really build the
entire state by reading in the first
couple of minutes so rather than knowing
which data you need and looking up
database at ba-ba-ba-ba-ba rather than
doing it remotely they did it locally
and then check pointed a maybe for these
cases we can do something better with
with containers and think like that but
there this is still the Juara is out and
and there is also a question with all
these technologies moving so fast that
if we invest in something and get it to
work there and then we wake up and
people started with daca in the science
community now everyone is doing
singularity singularity as its own part
and then singularity will move to
another version and suddenly they solve
a the the the dev up world is is pretty
pretty demanding and because we have to
build on stable and dependable services
that you know when by the way at the
footnote that i should have mentioned
and a we are one of the few i don't want
to say only but one of the few signs
middle words if you want to call it that
we have a pretty wide window deployment
we the Condor works very well on windows
and we have quite a bit including
commercial users that that are running
condo on windows and we made early on a
decision that that took us quite a bit
of effort but we did a deep
implementation a
according to Windows where we raised our
abstraction level to a point where we
can go to Linux UNIX and windows from
the same abstraction level because
earlier we were tied and rather than
trying to go through some kind of an
interpreter and all the kind of thing we
said we need the native Windows
implementation but we have quite a bit
of of users I would say more heavily in
the commercial world so since I
mentioned the commercial world just I
think that will be sort of a fun piece
so one of our users who who is using
condo is the dream work so the entire
rendering form of dream work which the
last time they reported that in one of
our meeting was 45,000 servers and a
15,000 desktop machines they are using
it to do all the production rendering a
delay the latest movie that they
released took 300 million core hours to
render so oh if you watched any of their
movies since 2011 that was released
since 2011 you are watching the you're
watching condor any other questions
thank you